it is my honor to present the oscar for
best director
alongside a legendary artist
since you graced our screens more than
60 years ago
your talent and integrity have
shattered barriers and inspired
audiences everywhere and for that my
friend we are very very much in your
debt
and
it is my pleasure to be here in such
inspiring company to
help celebrate all the extraordinary
talent represented tonight
it's in encouraging
and invigorating
please keep
up the wonderful work
here are the nominees for achievement in
directing
david o russell american hustle
alfonso claron gravity
alexander payne nebraska
steve mcqueen 12 years a slave
martin scorsese the wolf of wall street
all right here you go
and
the oscar goes to
they ask the girl do i get this one yes
all right
alfonso claro
well thank you thanks to to the academy
like any other human endeavor making a
film can be
a transformative experience and i want
to thank gravity
because for many of us involved in this
film it was definitely a transformative
experience
um and it's good because it took so long
that if not it would be
like a waste of time and
what it really sucks is that um
well for a lot of these people that
transformation was wisdom
for me was just the color of my hair the
uh i want to share this with all these
wise people who made this movie happen
uh my amazing son and co-writer
sandra bullock sandy your gravity
you are the soul the heart of the film
you're
the most amazing collaborator and one of
the best people i ever met
uh uh george clooney for you uh
absolutely trust uh david heyman
chibo and tim weber for making this film
happen
the wise guys of warner brothers they
the wise people at barnes brothers
came into shihara sukrull then fellman
greg silverman lin harris chris zafaria
and the film took so long that we went
through two different administrations so
i have two honor as well
uh alan horn and jeff robinov uh
alejandro gonzalez
guillermo del toro gabriela rodriguez
steve rabino henry holmes jim berkus and
tracy jacobs
and christine
and como
bye guys
you